understanding that the game plan is a
given those shots and I like the doc is
calling them back you're gonna have to
shoot that shot we're going to give it
to you all series long
hurry you cannot turn the ball over
against this explosive warrior team in
transition but that's a ridiculous shot
like curry again using a loony screen
wall Carroll's back to curry for three
gets the bounce rebounds he will not be
out competing that's a phrase Steph
Curry from downtown his third
three-pointer curry wide open three it's
good for three pointers to kur curry
another offensive rebound curry for
three bucks ahead
this look at Steph Curry rebound a
basketball lulls you to sleep gets to
his spot elevates that's contest that's
not allowing him to land
this look at Steph Curry rebound a
basketball lulls you to sleep gets to
his spot elevates that's contest that's
not allowing him to land all-time great
shooting and basketball player temple
bumping into him there with his 12
rebound of the game curry long distance
that should have been a foul both ends
of the floor here in Game one and he's
always such a barometer for when this
team is dominant Curry's foot three
seven threes for Curry's just tied Ray
Allen
for most playoff threes in NBA history
it will help off the screen realizing
that you're doubling on the block own
teeth rebound curry for Trey bucks it